all right oh this is so weird okay so I
think you guys have talked about this
before where there have always been
rumors about Will Smith and his wife
Jada Pinkett Smith being an open
relationship or they're swingers a
couple of days ago
the singer August Alsina came out on to
Angela's show and he talked about how he
was in a relationship a couple years ago
with Jada Pinkett Smith and he was just
kind of talking about how uh it was a
really good relationship and he loves
someone so deeply and then he went on to
say that he talked to Will Smith about
being in a relationship with her and
that Will Smith gave him his blessing
and a lot of people went crazy about
that to the point where Jada Pinkett
Smith went onto her show read.table
talked with her husband where they
talked about it she said that she and
will were at the time amicably separated
and they were gonna get a divorce and
that was the time when she started
dating the singer and when Will Smith
asked her what what it was he kind of
wanted her to say that she was having an
affair and instead she used the term
entanglement which then went viral
because she refused to say that she was
in a relationship with him and she she
said she was an entanglement which then
went viral on Twitter and a bunch of
celebrities went out and DM dwelle
Smith's shortly after that interview
went live and there are text
conversations between 50 cent and Will
Smith as well as Will Smith in the
comedian Michael Blackson
he's funny screenshots um what's tough
is you know if you're real Smith's
period when you watch that and his wife
goes you know and will you and I weren't
doing it at the time and I had an
entanglement with August you can see the
pain on Will Smith's face man it
Watts you just tell like the
embarrassment in the pain and then he
goes well you know I'm gonna get you
back like what Argost I'll see is a
good-looking fella
yeah kind of handsome dude I looked them
up and I was like huh oh well all right
I don't want to August Alsina
near my girl and I don't want Chris
Brown near my girl there it's hard to
compete with I don't try to do this
minute new your girl either man well
yeah that's true cuz he's got a great
personality too
anyway handsome son of a Will
Smith is to hang out then August a lot
more fun than Bryan Callen yes right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]